hey youtubers it's Charlie hopefully you
guys have had a chance to see ant-man
it's a lot of fun it's like Marvel's
first real movie in a long time it's not
just a plain old rollercoaster I've
already done my non-spoilery review so
what I'm gonna do is Easter eggs first
like all the Easter eggs from the movie
and then I'm gonna talk about the
logical jumping off points for where the
sequels will go and what's happening
with phase three based on what they did
with the characters so let's go spoiler
warning if you haven't seen the movie
let's get going so starting off at the
beginning so we get to see John Slattery
again playing old Howard Stark this is
essentially shield we're at the
Triskelion here we get this the old
piggy Carter - so this is just
confirmation that Hank Pym did work with
shield for time till they tried to
weaponize his Pym particles it was
actually Mitchell Carson he plays the
corporate douchebag that later ends up
being a Hydra douchebag
he's actually a comic book character
himself he appeared during the Erik
O'Grady run he was supposed to take the
ant-man suit and wear it for shield but
then Erik O'Grady got it both of those
characters both Erik O'Grady and
Mitchell Carson are super jerks so it's
not just in the movie moving on to the
Milgram Hotel you may have seen that
name really prominently al Milgram drew
West Coast Avengers it featured a lot of
Hank Pym but not while he was ant-man
Darren cross kind of jams in a tales to
astonish easter-egg it it felt a little
forced but they're just they're honoring
the classic ant-man stories that comic
was just where the ant-man character
debuted he didn't start out in his own
solo title is it's the same deal with
spider-man like spider-man didn't start
out in spider-man later Paul Rudd
suggests that they call the Avengers and
then Hank Pym makes this really funny
joke about dropping cities on people
that movie places this between age of
Ultron but before Captain America Civil
War because of that in credit scene we
even get to see the New Avengers
facility whenever he tries to infiltrate
to get that small device do not tell
Captain Falcon got his ass handed to him
whenever he's first putting the ant-man
suit on when he whenever he climbs in
the shower to do that that's actually a
reference to the irredeemable ant-man
another Erik O'Grady storyline oh great
he actually shrunk himself down in the
shower to spy on Captain Marvel whenever
she was taking a shower yeah definitely
a dirtbag the interesting thing is is he
was actually created by Robert Kirkman
who created the Walking Dead later
whenever Pym suggested that
long term exposure to the Pym particles
had affected his mind had taken its toll
on him he's probably talking about the
time in the comics when he became
yellowjacket got brainwashed and hid
Janet Van Dyne whenever people talk
about him hitting his wife that that's
what they're talking about when he
became like the domestic abuser even
though that wasn't the original
intention of the comic that that's the
way it came across so that's the way
people remember it when Scott Lang
shrinks down and goes into the quantum
realm that's probably an easter egg for
the Microverse the Microverse is like
its own small universe like an ecosystem
with its own culture and group of
characters like there's actually stuff
that goes on in there there's living
beings that live in there they mentioned
it so many times and Scott Lang was able
to get out do not be surprised if they
explore that again in the sequel towards
the end of the movie we get our really
big spider-man Easter egg everyone went
really crazy about this one they say
there's a guy out there who can crawl up
walls that that's obviously a reference
to spider-man in New York City Tom Haun
was just cast as the character but Kevin
Feige said that this line was in the
movie before they ever made the deal
with Sony like like it was in a really
early draft of the script Stan Lee
spotted as the bartender at the end I
don't really consider that an easter egg
but it is really funny that girl at the
end the girl in the bar that was
lip-syncing that was Anna Akana
she's just like a very prominent
youtuber I just I always love seeing
youtubers show up in really big
Hollywood movies and then we have the
wasp suit so very clearly hope Van Dyne
will be the wasp of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe when we had the flashback we
saw the classic version of the costume
her mother's version this looks pretty
close to that it doesn't have the yellow
on it but with each new Marvel movie
suits get bigger more shiny so we could
see a slightly different version of this
whenever she actually debuts as the wasp
and Kevin Feige did confirmed that she
would be the wasp in a phase 3 movie he
didn't say which one I'm really hoping
that it's gonna be Captain America Civil
War but it might be too soon for that
at least Avengers infinity war so when
Evangeline Lilly said it's about damn
time it was kind of a meta thing and
then very clearly the the Bucky Easter
Egg at the end is just a tee up for
Captain America Civil War the reason he
was being all shady about it is because
he was talking about the Accords it
sounds like the movies version of the
superhero Registration Act like if he
were to bring
bunkie out in public he would have to
stand trial for all the things that he's
done and cap doesn't want that to happen
so he's trying to keep his secret from
Tony and everyone else so he's going to
need a thief to help him reverse steal
Bucky so there are any other Easter eggs
in the movie that you guys saw just
write them below in the comments they're
probably a whole bunch of other ones
most of them I thought were pretty
verbal but there were a couple of the
really obvious ones like the wasp
costume there were actually a lot of
people in my audience that you know they
didn't get super excited about the movie
until they saw the wasp costume and they
started freaking out in the theater he
did something to get really excited
about Evangeline Lilly's a lot of fun I
think she's gonna fit that character
like a glove well you could make all
kinds of jokes about the suit fitting
even though the suits are custom made to
fit the actors so for those asking you
know why hank pym has never shown up or
never been mentioned in any of the other
Marvel movies we kind of got the answer
he hates the Avengers he thinks they're
all douchebags mostly Howard Stark and
as he said he wants nothing to do with
his son so I'm talking about Tony Stark
even though Paul Rudd has been seen on
set for Captain America's Civil War I'll
be interested to see when they bring
Michael Douglas back mitt you know maybe
like a brief small cameo scene he is
still like Tony Stark levels of
brilliant and even though Scott Lang is
smart enough to tinker with the ant-man
suit I feel like they're still gonna
need Hanks help to perfect the wasp suit
speaking of which the sequel obviously
going to double down on the hope wasp
character what I'd really like to see
them do is explore the quantum realm the
Microverse because that's that's like a
place that dr. strange could travel any
number of the new Marvel characters that
can cross space and time but let me know
what do you really want to see the
sequel explore Kevin Feige
implied that if the movie did well
enough that they would fast-track a
sequel you know we might see it before
the end of phase 3 even though
technically they've already announced
all their phase 3 movies currently the
Inhumans is the last movie on the
schedule right now it's happening after
infinity War part 2 so unless we hear
otherwise I'm just expecting to see
ant-man too after that but like I said
if ant-man makes a ton of money then
they'll try and get the sequel out
faster just in case I neglected to
mention it too just you know just
overall rating I would rate this movie
eight out of ten for valuing characters
over the theme-park ride but there are a
couple of theme park rides in the movie
you have Thomas the Tank Engine like if
you saw the movie in 3d then you know
exactly what I'm talking about Corey
Stoll felt like he handed up just like a
little bit but they made this movie so
fast and they did dial back his
on-screen presence like you basically
you had to explain how this scientist
was going insane from exposure to the
Pym particles if you wondered why he was
acting so crazy it was because of that
so 'hammied Aaron cross aside I felt
like everyone delivered really great
performances in Michael Pena I forgot to
mention him in my video he really stole
all the comedic scenes every every scene
he was in but let me know who is your
favorite actor in the film you know good
or bad the only characters that I know
will be back in other Avengers films not
not just the sequel will be hope and
Scott you know maybe maybe Michael
Douglas small chance of him in case you
haven't seen it I just did a video on
vixen she's gonna be a brand new
crossover show with air on the flash
except that it's animated it's it's a
little bit different what they're doing
with it you can click here for the
trailer learn all about it it's gonna
start at the end of August and you can
click here for all of my Marvel phase 3
videos so you can learn what's going on
with spider-man in Civil War thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you